Good morning Hank, it's Tuesday.
I'm wearing a suit jacket, which can only mean one thing!
It's time for the Bank of Nerdfighteria's quarterly report.
Or that I'm at a funeral,
but I'm not at a funeral!
So the Bank of Nerdfighteria has three branches.
There's the executive branch, which probably has too much power,
The judicial branch, which literally believes that corporations are people,
and then there's the legislative branch,
which, presumably, was named ironically,
since it hasn't passed meaningful legislation in nearly a decade.
Wait! No, I'm thinking about a different institution.
The Bank of Nerdfighteria's three branches are:
The giving branch,
the lending branch,
and the spending branch.
Let's start with the giving branch.
The Foundation to Decrease World Suck, our actual, real life charity,
has finished paying out well over a million dollars in grants from the 2015 Project For Awesome.
The money went to all the organizations listed here,
and it's doing lots of good all over the world.
For instance, I recently heard from water.org
that Nerdfighteria has just funded a capped spring water well in Northern Ethiopia
that serves over two thousand people.
So far, this year,
the Foundation to Decrease World Suck has just over seventy-three thousand dollars in the bank.
Most of that money comes from 'vlogbrothers' ad revenue.
Right now, half of this revenue goes to the Foundation to Decrease World Suck,
and half goes to sponsor education projects.
So, thank you for watching the ad before this video!
Hopefully there was an ad...
Okay, let's move on to the lending branch.
The Nerdfighter Kiva Group has now loaned more than 7.4 million dollars to entrepreneurs around the world -
also, more info about this in the dooblydoo -
but Kiva's made some important steps to improve outcomes with their partners lately.
And then, Hank, there are two very exciting updates from the spending branch of our bank.
So, in 2016, four CrashCourse videos have gone up each week.
Like, currently, we're discussing:
literature,
the history of games,
physics,
and philosophy.
But starting September first,
all the CrashCourse Patreon money raised for the remainder of 2016
will go to fund an expansion of CrashCourse in 2017.
This will mean 5 videos a week by the spring of 2017,
and hopefully 6 videos a week by the end of the year;
including our first forays into higher ed' topics like advanced physics and anthropology.
And we're really excited to be growing more.
Also, we're working to systematically translate CrashCourse videos into multiple languages.
By the way, if you happen to have the talent and time to volunteer to help with that translation project,
please let us know via the form in the dooblydoo.
So, yeah, thanks to everyone's help on Patreon,
more Crash Course videos next year, available in more languages.
And lastly!
For more than a year now, Joe and Stan in our office have been working with help and funding,
from Bill Gates' BGC3 organization,
to build out educational materials around Crash Course videos.
Like, as you may be aware,
textbooks are ridiculously, astonishingly, stupefyingly expensive,
and we've always felt like maybe a better price for them
would be, you know, FREE.
Because if high-quality curriculum materials were available for free online,
it would allow schools to save money on textbooks,
and invest that money in their most important resource,
which is teachers.
So last week, Crash Course released its first full curriculum,
which covers AP World History,
with readings and primary sources,
and assessment tools, for both students and teachers.
Hopefully, it's like a textbook, plus worksheets and writing prompts,
except it's easily downloadable,
frequently updated,
and free.
You can find it all at TheCrashCourse.com,
or there's a link in the dooblydoo below,
but we're really looking forward to getting feedback
from teachers and students,
so we can continue to update and improve the curriculum.
This is just the beginning, and it's only one course,
but we're VERY excited about it, so please check it out;
share it with your teachers!
And hopefully we'll find funding to create more full courses in the future.
I wanna, again, thank everyone at BGC3,
and also everyone who supports CrashCourse on Patreon.
You can find CrashCourse's Patreon by clicking here,
or there is a link down in the dooblydoo.
There are lots of great perks available to Patrons,
although, by far, the biggest perk is knowing that, without you, CrashCourse literally would not exist,
so thanks.
So that's the update from the Bank of Nerdfighteria!
Nerdfighters, if you have questions, I will be in comments.
Hank! DFTBA! I will see you on Friday.